all right new rule unless the projection
is did something absolutely amazing
don't clap at the end of a movie I hate
to be the one to break this to you but
iron man can't hear you you're
applauding a light bulb clapping for a
movie is like tipping an inflatable sex
doll
a slow gathering applause it took many
years but the applause came in neural if
you stop at one of those dumpy casinos
right over the Nevada border because
Vegas is another 30 minutes away and you
just can't wait that long you have to go
to a meeting near all sports
illustrated' has to stop patting itself
on the back for using a model who is
plus-sized okay first of all this isn't
the plus-size model it's a regular-sized
human being
you're just used to - sighs bulimics as
is this male model which is why he's
touching her like what is this flesh
weird they're all stop putting sriracha
on everything I I hate to break it to
you Millennials but it's just hot sauce
so it's not gonna get you backstage at
Coachella or pay off your student loan
all it's good for is spicing up the mac
and cheese that you'll be eating for the
rest of your life because because all
the good jobs went to guys without neck
tattoos
knurl now that scientists have decided
that sugar will kill you but fat is
awesome
coca-cola must come out with a new beef
flavored soft drink called mr. meat with
no sugar and 50 grams of heart-healthy
saturated fat and don't forget to try
miss mr. meat with sriracha